how's it going everybody it's Warren and
if you thought fan OHS was done in the
MCU and Marvel was done using this
character well you should think again
fan OHS was one of the biggest baddest
villains that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has ever seen and he's one of
the biggest baddest villains that Marvel
in general has ever seen and even though
he definitely got his fair share of
screen time first appearing in the first
Avengers film and the post-credits scene
all the way up to getting basically his
own movie in Avengers infinity war and
then seeing him again in Avengers in
game it appears that Marvel is not done
with him yet in fact it seems like we
could see him as early on as phase four
so let's talk about how fan oohs is
going to re-enter the MCU real quick
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
with notifications turned on like the
video and comment below so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 now for those of you who
are worried that his reappearance in the
MCU is going to take away from Avengers
infinity war or Avengers in game or
anything that has happened in the MCU
have no fear Thanos isn't going to be
returning from the dead although that
wouldn't be too surprising if it
happened but instead we are going to see
a young fan oohs before he went out on
his quest to balance the universe and
seek out the Infinity stones and we are
apparently going to see this in the
Eternals now this makes a lot of sense
and several sources have reported this
for some time now it makes sense because
Thanos is actually an eternal he's the
son of two Eternals a Lars who was
mentioned in Avengers infinity war by
Red Skull and Swee son he however
inherited the deviant gene which is why
he has all the scars on his face why
he's a little bit deformed and why he's
purple now we already know that the
Eternals movie is going to take a dive
into the history of the Eternals but not
only the Eternals they're also going to
explore the deviants as well now the
Eternals and deviants were made by the
celestial gods they are essentially
immortal they live for thousands and
thousands of years and it's been
reported that the Eternals is even going
to go back seven thousand years prior to
the MCU and that's where we're going to
see fan o's re-enter the MCU and today
it seems like we have some specifics
about when exactly we're going to see
Fanus according to sources close to we
got this covered we are going to see fan
o's appear two times in the Eternals
according to this
poor the script has two cameos for
Thanos to appear one as a child and one
as an adult the first scene is
reportedly Thanos back on Titan as an
infant with his brother starfox
and this scene is apparently in the form
of a flashback the next scene in cameo
of Thanos is when he is an adult and
this apparently takes place right before
the events of the MCU start to happen we
see Thinnes and starfox again Thanos has
gone to his brother starfox to ask him
for help in finding the Infinity stones
now if the Eternals movie is going to
explore the history and the past of the
Eternals that makes sense that these
scenes would be in there obviously since
Thanos decided to commit mass genocide
he would be one of the more well known
eternals and not to mention that it's
the job of the Eternals to protect earth
so where exactly were they during the
eleven year time span of the Infinity
Saga for a race of immortal beings whose
job is to protect earth they sure didn't
really do a good job Loki invaded earth
with Thanos army Ultron almost destroyed
the earth and one of their own Thanos
eliminated half of the population of the
universe which probably included some of
their own so what exactly were they
doing this entire time well that's
something that the Eternals movie is
hopefully going to explore and Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has recently mentioned that the Eternals
know who the Avengers are however the
Avengers or anybody else does not know
who the Eternals are but these are all
things that are going to be explored
during the Eternals movie including the
destruction of their home planet Titan
and with that of course some of the
story of the mad Titan Thanos so it
seems like we're going to be getting a
little bit more of the backstory of
Thanos in the form of flashbacks and the
Eternals and perhaps we could learn
about a bigger and badder villain in the
Eternals Galactus it has been rumored
that mentions of Galactus could happen
in the Eternals so the Eternals is
shaping out to be an amazing and very
important movie to the MCU one where we
will once again see the mad Titan Thanos
so let me know what you think about this
do you like the fact that he's going to
be returning but only in flashbacks or
would you rather have the mad Titan live
and somehow return be sure to comment
with your thoughts down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
with notifications turned on so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox
one or a ps4 the winner gets to choose
and I'm picking a winner at five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers don't
forget to click the link below for your
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet and
don't forget to use code cosmic @ G feel
calm for 30% off G fuel as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof